Okay. Welcome back to Garys Economics.
Today
we are going to ask
the question is the UK government bankrupt?
Okay.
So we are doing an emergency shoot today
on Friday the 10th of January
because I wanted to cover
this developing situation,
which could end up being really significant.
I don't think it's being covered very well on the news
and I wanted to make sure you understood
what's happening.
So this story is mainly about the interest rate
that the government has to pay when it borrows money.
And that interest rate
has been gradually increasing over the
course of the last year.
That interest rate has been gradually increasing
for the last sort of three, four months.
And it's increased really aggressively
in the last few weeks.
The interest rate that the
government has to pay at the moment, right now
is about 4.83%.
And that is raising questions
about basically whether the UK government
is financially sustainable, essentially.
And it's very realistically possible
that these sudden increases in UK
government borrowing rates
will force the UK government
into basically making emergency cuts in its spending.
Which you probably could describe
as a return to austerity.
But I think the most important thing
is, first of all, we explain really clearly
what is happening here
and why is
that an interest rate of just under
5% is so dangerous for the UK.
So if you look historically and I've got a graph here
and I think we'll pop them up,
If you look at historical
interest rates that the UK government paid,
on its borrowings,
the current rate,
which is just under 5%, was super,
super normal in the 2000’s before the financial crisis.
And if you go back to the 90s,
they used to pay significantly higher rates or 6%,
7% back in the 80s, even higher rates than that.
So why is it that now
that the
rate is just under 5%,
people are really worried
about the UK financial situation?
In order to explain that,
we need to talk about why it is
that governments are able to borrow every year.
So governments do this really interesting thing
where pretty much every year
they spend more than they tax,
which means they borrow money every year.
And yet the amount of debt that they have
as a proportion of GDP,
as a proportion of the size of the total economy
often doesn't go up.
So how do governments do this kind of magic trick
where they borrow money every year,
and yet their debt doesn't go up?
Okay, so the key thing that you want
to understand about debt
is that
what matters for government
financial sustainability
is not so much the size of the debt itself.
It's the size of the debt
compared to the overall size of the economy, which
we usually call GDP.
So.
The government borrows more money
every year, which causes debt to go up.
And the reason they get away with this
is because GDP is also constantly increasing.
Now why is GDP increasing.
So GDP growth can be broken down into two things.
The first one is the thing
that you often hear about in the news,
which is economic growth.
So you know,
the UK economy at the moment is growing
about 1% a year.
But one other reason
that governments get away borrowing more every year
is inflation.
Now,
what you need to understand about inflation is,
inflation doesn't affect the size of your debt.
So if you borrow money from the bank,
you borrow, say, £1,000.
You have to pay back £1,000 plus 5% interest.
That's £1,050..
That is £1,050. No matter what inflation is.
So if inflation is really, really high, say 20%,
you're only paying 5% interest.
But the price of everything else is going up.
The people's wages are going up.
The goods and services are going up.
Food, energy is going up.
So inflation also causes
GDP to rise.
One way to think about this is that
inflation is the devaluation of money.
If you want to think about that, you can get the,
you can watch the devaluation of money
video on our channel.
But inflation causes
GDP to rise and it doesn't cause debt to rise.
So basically
GDP has this double boost,
double boost, one from economic growth
and one from inflation.
And that means that debt can afford to rise
without debt over GDP from increasing.
The problem we have with debt
is that we have to pay interest.
So essentially there's three forces here.
Interest.
Pushes your debt up.
And inflation
and growth.
Push your GDP up.
So really what matters is comparing these three things.
Okay. So what's inflation.
So inflation was very high the last few years.
But at the moment
inflation is down back to around target.
It's currently around 3%.
But the Bank of England targets inflation at 2%, 2.5%.
Well its target is actually 2%.
But if you look historically
it does tend to be a bit higher than that over time.
If we assume that the Bank of England
slightly misses its target
and long term inflation is 2.5%,
that helps us because it’s going to keep GDP rising.
Growth at the moment, and
this is the big problem in the UK, is only 1%.
Add these two things together
3.5%.
Excuse my terrible handwriting.
What's debt interest now?
Debt interest is changing literally
while I make the video.
Debt interest
at the moment is 4.86%.
This is your big problem.
4.96% is
significantly more than 3.5%,
which means
unless the government
does something managed to increase growth,
the debt is going to grow faster than GDP over time.
And debt as a proportion of GDP is going to grow.
The only way for them to prevent
that from happening is either to increase inflation,
to increase economic growth,
get the interest rate down,
or it has to run a budget surplus,
which basically means taxing from you
more than it gives to you in spending.
in a sense, this makes it clear why
the financial situation
after, for example,
2008, when government debt increased significantly,
was less worrying
than, from the perspective of, say,
the UK than it is now.
And that is because after 2008,
we had this very, very long
period of basically zero interest rates,
which meant that the government could borrow,
at sort of 2%, even 1% at times.
And since inflation is around 2%,
if you can borrow at 1%,
that debt is just going to stay quite stable.
It's going to go up by 1% every year
and down by 2% every year.
And effectively,
the government basically pays no interest at all.
But as these interest rates push up
more and more and more and more and more.
It creates this potential
for a negative kind of debt spiral dynamic.
And I've been watching these interest rates
because a normal rate of sort
of inflation plus growth is something like
3.5%, maybe 4%.
As it starts to rise above 4%,
it gets more and more worrying
Okay.
So that's your explanation
of how to understand
basically whether the government interest rate
is a problem or not.
You need to understand what is
GDP growth at the moment it’s around 1%.
Of course, Labour
would like you to think it's going to go higher
and maybe it will.
Inflation is probably around 2%, 2.5%.
So as long as interest rates
are pushing above four and a half, the higher
they get, the more difficult it will be.
And if the government doesn't want debt
to increase over time,
it has no choice basically,
but to start taxing more than it spends.
Basically extracting that money from ordinary people.
So this has become
a big
talking point in financial markets
in the last few days.
The first thing I will say is
people are obviously going to compare this
to the Liz Truss situation.
That is pretty unfair.
I think the Liz Truss situation was really chaotic,
and it was
basically brought upon itself by some wild decisions
by Liz Truss and her government.
What has happened here is
the UK was already in a difficult situation
because the debt was increased
so significantly during Covid,
and they sort of tried to toe this middle ground of,
we're not going to tax the rich more,
we're going to borrow, we're going to be sensible.
Whenever your plan is based on borrowing,
there's always the risk that interest rates will go up.
In the last few months, interest rates have increased
all around the world,
and the government has been kind of using
that to defend itself.
They're saying this is not a UK government mistake.
This is moves in global interest rates.
It's caused by,
people are a bit worried about what Donald Trump
might do when it comes in.
That is all true.
But the fact of the matter is.
With interest rates where they are at the moment,
it is very possible
the government can't afford to fund itself long term.
And that is why a move in global interest rates
that have pushed
everybody's borrowing rates up
has hit specifically the UK.
And we can explain that,
why it's the UK specifically,
largely by showing you a list.
And I'll bring this list up
of what different countries in the world pay to borrow.
So you can see here
comparing the UK to European countries,
the UK pays about 4.83%.
The highest rate paid by any other large
European country is Italy, which is 3.74%,
which is a fall more than 1% below.
Now remember, growth
plus inflation is probably going to be about 3.5%, 4%.
So Italy at 3.74%,
that growth is not going to grow over...
that debt is not going to grow over time
as a percentage of the economy.
Whereas that UK number 4.83%,
potentially will grow as a percentage of the economy.
Okay, so the UK situation is particularly bad.
Interest rates go pushed up across the world.
Traders start to look at that UK
number 4.93% and question
whether the UK financial situation is sustainable.
That caused on, well,
yesterday morning, Thursday morning,
a bit of a panic in markets. The bonds started sell.
The interest rates started to rise quickly.
What does that mean for you.
What does that mean for the government?
The government cannot allow a panic
to occur in these bond markets because
if that rate starts to rise, really quickly,
if it rises to 5.1%, 5.2%, 5.3%,
every little bit that goes up
makes it more questionable
whether the government can afford to fund itself.
And as it becomes more and more questionable
whether the government can fund itself,
the borrowers want higher and higher rates
because they're worried that the government
won’t be able to pay it back.
And that creates a real risk for a negative spiral.
You know, we all saw what happened to Liz Truss.
The government's made a big deal out of Liz Truss.
The government absolutely need to prevent this.
So what can the government do?
What will the government do?
Financial markets will basically demand,
that the government
reduce their deficit.
You can reduce your deficit in two ways.
You can either increase taxes or you can cut spending.
If the government is forced to do something
very quickly,
it's very unlikely
that they have done the preparation
for a wide variety of tax rises.
They will probably be forced to cut spending.
That would be so devastating
politically for an already unpopular government.
Who made a lot out of Liz Truss's failings
that they will probably do anything to avoid it.
And what they will do
and what they have been doing over
the last couple of days
is basically really aggressively
trying to wink at the financial markets and say,
we're going to do the cuts, but
wait till March.
And the reason they want to do that
is because when March is
when the next sort of fiscal statement is
they want it to look orderly.
They want to say, listen, in the last few months,
interest rates have risen.
We're responding and we're cutting.
They don't want to seem like it's
a kind of a second Liz Truss moment.
Now this plays into something
which Labour made a lot
about in their election campaign,
which is Labour's fiscal rules.
There's a few fiscal rules,
but the one that is most relevant here
is that Labour have promised to stabilise this thing,
which we have been speaking about in this whole video.
They want to stabilise debt
as a proportion of GDP,
as a proportion of the overall economy.
As we discussed before, debt rises with interest.
So as the interest rate goes up,
unless you can get GDP growth out of somewhere,
the only way to stop the debt from rising
as a percentage of your GDP is to have inflation
or basically to cut your deficit,
to start taxing more, to reduce your spending.
So the government,
if they want to follow their own fiscal rules,
they basically cannot help
but be driven by financial markets.
If something happens like has happened
in this last couple of weeks,
and interest rates rise significantly
because the government has set this fiscal rule,
the government basically has to do cuts.
And unless financial markets turn around quickly,
it's going up, going up as I speak,
unless financial markets turn around quickly.
Really, there's only
two possible things that can happen,
which is the government manages
to convince markets to wait till March,
does its cuts in March.
Or if things get really bad
in the next couple of weeks,
the government might even be forced
to do some kind of emergency statement
where they, where they announce cuts.
Basically.
Either way,
the financial markets are going to enforce austerity
again on you by your government Okay.
Now I'm covering this now as it moves.
And I don't want to like,
panic people.
This could go one of two ways, right?
Either the market calms down in the next few weeks.
The government is able to wait till March,
or it keeps going,
and the government is forced to
do cuts more imminently.
Either way, this means austerity.
If this goes the most serious way
and I don't think this is probable,
but it's definitely possible.
If it calls Starmer and Reeves out
to make an emergency statement of cuts,
given how little political capital they have.
It could potentially
end the Starmer, Reeves government.
I don't think they would replace them immediately.
But
it could leave them in a sort of Theresa
May situation where they're left on as a dead duck,
where it would look really bad.
It will look really, really bad
if they were forced to suddenly backtrack
in a similar way to Liz Truss did.
And to be fair,
I think they would be unlucky if that happened,
because what they have done...
and I think this brings me to my next point,
which I wanted to make,
which is a lot of people in the media
will say
that this is because
especially if it gets more serious,
they will say that this is because of the budget.
The budget back last year.
And I think that would be
a pretty bad representation of what's really happening.
The budget was pretty f***ing mild in my opinion.
It was a pretty milk toast budget.
They slightly... they did slightly increased borrowing.
They slightly increased taxes,
they slightly increased spending.
But it was a very moderate budget.
And I don't think we should be surprised by that
because Starmer and Reeves are kind of defined
in a sense, by their economic sensibleness
and their economic moderation.
I think the problem that you have,
is that
the financial situation was pretty terrible coming in.
And, when I say this, you know,
I think I'm
sort of going to go down
the classic Labour line of, oh,
this is the Tories, blame the Tories, but
I'm not going to do that.
Really, what is happening now
is in a sense, the inevitable consequence is not of
the budget last year, but of the
really terrible economic mismanagement of Covid.
Now, if you go back, I mention it a lot...
look at the opening, the first video
we ever shot on this channel.
I spoke a lot about the massive accumulation of cash
by the rich and how that would cause
an inflation crisis and cost of living crisis
and an inequality crisis.
But one other thing that I mentioned there
was that
this money that went to the rich
came from the government,
and it would cause
and did cause a massive, massive increase
in government debt and a massive decrease in
basically government financial sustainability.
And at the time, it wasn't easy to know
whether that would lead to austerity or not.
And the reason for that is basically
because of the things
that we've discussed in this video.
After 2008,
we entered a period of extremely low interest rates,
which meant that the government could,
if it wanted, have continued to borrow and continue
to spend without really damaging
financial sustainability,
because when interest rates are very, very low,
they’re lower than inflation your government debt
simply cannot spiral out of control.
There was always the risk
when you massively increased your government debt
of coming into the kind of situation we are in now.
If interest rates ever go up,
then basically
your government becomes a slave to financial markets
and the financial markets can force you to cut.
The financial markets can force you
to reverse your policy.
That's what they did to Liz Truss.
That's what they did to Greece back in the 2010s.
This is an inevitable part
of allowing your financial situation to deteriorate.
And if you ask me, the real mistakes were made here
in 2020, 2021, 2022, when we knew
the government was going
to give an enormous amount of money out,
and we had a period of two years of lockdown
when we could have said, okay, who's
gonna end up with that money?
How are we going to get the money back?
How can we deal with our taxation policy?
How can we restore the government financial position?
And basically we didn't do it.
And I want to add to that, you know,
I'm not saying furlough shouldn't have happened.
I'm not saying the government didn't
need to spend an enormous amount of money.
That money was used to
give people the money they
need to pay their rent, to buy their food
when they weren't able to work.
We had three years to discuss the questions of
where's the money gone? Where's the money ended up?
How is it going to affect distribution?
Can we get the money back?
And really what you see here
is the result of a long period of phenomenal naivety
regarding the importance of resources.
Resources and distribution.
What you saw
during Covid
was the government
giving an enormous amount of money away.
That money went to the rich.
The rich can use that money
to buy the resources from the middle class, to buy
resources ordinary people need.
You've lost your resources.
I've said this before
and I'm going to say this again and again.
If you give all your resources away,
you are left with two choices.
Try and get your resources back,
which in this case means
finding ways to tax
the super rich who've got that money now,
or accept poverty.
And I think what we're seeing now is increasingly
this attempt at a third way,
which the current Labour government are trying
is not going to work.
It's not going to work.
It's possible that we get lucky.
Interest rates start to fall over the next
few weeks, months.
Now, inflation will fall over the next six months.
Bank of England base rates will very likely fall.
This situation could improve.
It's very, very difficult.
It's very, very, very difficult
to borrow your way out of a hole.
One thing I want to say is,
I know there'll be a lot of people here
that will say, listen,
we shouldn't let financial markets dominate our
government policy.
We shouldn't let financial markets
dominate our fiscal policy.
You know, I agree with that.
If you don't want financial markets
to dominate your governmental policy.
You cannot give all your resources to the rich
and have your financial plan be borrow them back.
This is what happens.
If you give all your resources away
and your plan is to borrow them back,
then you will be at the mercy
of the interest rates of the lenders,
the interest rates of the traders,
the interest rates of the rich.
The only way to defend your resources
once you've given them away
is to work on your taxation policy.
And we should be in a situation
now where we don't need to borrow from the rich
because we are able to tax
on the super rich
and use that to get our resources back
and use those resources
to provide the goods and services that you need.
But we're trying to toe this middle path of borrowing,
give all our resources away, try and borrow them back.
This is the risk that you take.
The last thing I want to say is,
I know that this crisis
looks quite UK specific at the moment.
There are a lot of countries
that are not further down the line on this.
The situation in the US is slightly better
because they have higher growth.
The situation in Australia is slightly better
The situation in European countries is slightly better
because the interest rates are lower.
If interest rates keep going,
your country could be next.
You need to protect your resources.
The resources have been given to the rich.
If you don't fix your taxation policy,
you will have no choice but to slowly
shut down
your welfare states
and your countries
will look like impoverished countries,
like India, like South Africa, like Brazil.
Go to those countries. See how ordinary people live.
That can come here, that can come to your country,
that can come to my country.
I don't want to panic you.
This might resolve itself. This could get worse.
Living standards will keep deteriorating
unless we get our resources back.
That means taxing, not just borrowing.
Thanks for your help. Good luck.